we are having such an amazing time at
comic-con and it turns out a good friend
of the show is also here in San Diego he
wanted to stop by and say hello
please welcome TJ Miller
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm waving you can't tell but I'm waving
yeah that's great hey TJ good to see ya
hello
Conan yeah I gotta say I love this
costume it's fantastic no oh this whole
thing yeah I don't hate any I only put
this on when I don't care what I look
like now Cody and I decided to get into
the comic-con spirit oh right so our
costume play but those in the business
who business of being nerdy perverts
called cosplay
[Applause]
yeah and so I'm Cossack
I'm the Iron Throne from game yes we
knew that yeah yeah yeah big surprise
you know you do looked uncomfortable TJ
you have to say that that is correct
cause when I built this costume I did
not think well I used real actual iron
real iron is that that is that the case
really this is will
Conan listen to how it sounds here hit
it again okay all right
wait back into this sketch hey you're
not kidding
it's made of real iron that's got to be
incredibly heavy TJ indeed it is mr.
O'Brien I can barely move and I am
sweating more than a caterer at the red
wedding yeah sort of walking around
going who had the fish oh no everyone's
killed they've all died well what a
great waste of halibut okay listen and
that was a hell of a joke yeah that was
a good one that was a good one
TJ if it's so hot and uncomfortable in
there once you get out who would that I
could Conan O'Brien would that I could
okay
I've welded myself in oh you're welded
into it it's a good god that's insane TJ
prison of my own devising and yes it is
insane yeah Onan but not as insane as
the smell that is emitting from within
oh my B oh my body odor is it a constant
struggle with the swamp stench that is
my under chassis for odor supremacy ah
it's really we don't want to hear about
that it's disgusting okay I'm not going
I'm experiencing intense itch it's
driving me quite mad and I don't want to
say where the itch is but it ain't easy
to find
okay yeah hey hey posted is such taint
nothin yeah yeah yeah everybody I got it
thank you for stopping by TJ Miller
you're a fantastic gentlemen thank you
for being here
they're not going anywhere
I can't feel my legs are armed I'm
nothing I'm not even a person anymore
I'm an object
well then I'll do this I can just sit on
yeah yeah
[Applause]
you